hey guys it's day 1 of a 3 2015 and I am
joined by Alex who has been to see Star
Wars Battlefront yeah I have actually
got to play the co-op mode of star wars
battlefront which is kind of like a
horde mode right okay so yesterday we
saw the gameplay trailer of the
multiplayer right but you actually got
to see a bit more about the co-op mode
tell us a bit more about it so the co-op
mode is a two player either local or
online screen like the split screen is
what I played it's a two player horde
mode sort of thing you you take on a
increasingly difficult waves of enemies
and stormtroopers yeah there's
stormtroopers and you know the one that
I played it 3-1 and 80s you later on
it's right different ranks of drum
troopers so the biggest thing is that he
gets like significantly harder over the
six rounds that I played okay so like
any hold movie but bigger and bigger and
bigger way yeah right yep the difference
with is this hormone actually has an end
so the one that we played ended at six
rounds the one in the game they told me
would end at 15 rounds right okay I've
been playing lots of old boats over the
years and i'm bored silly of them what
what makes this one interesting so i'm
going to start with the the good parts
first so what i thought i was really
special about this is just a star wars
battlefront so it looks really really
cool yeah and the graphical fidelity
itself is like it you know it's pretty
good but the presentation in the style
of star wars battlefront of what I saw
it was amazing like they made it look
like a movie what you being on to tell
us more about how they made it looks a
filmic so I'm going to tell you like my
favorite moment in the demo I played in
the favorite Mona actually from the
trailer yet the gameplay trailer
yesterday was when I was playing a third
person and I zoomed in over the over the
shoulder of the pro of my character to
line up a shot with the blaster against
stormtroopers running like horizontally
across the screen and either like lead
the shots of the blaster a little bit
and when those shots hit the
stormtroopers it looked like I'm moving
like like sparks fly doubt it the storm
troopers were you know they were running
and their animations were exactly like
the Star Wars movies the way the shots
hit them was like exactly like the Star
Wars movies and it just looked like it
was straight out of the movie right so
you actually had said they were like
running this way and you had to like
line up the show so yeah yeah actually
don't even a little bit like there is a
very soon there is a significant time
difference between when I pull
trigger and when the you know the shot
landed where I was aiming so I delete it
and I felt it felt like I was actually
you know kind of in the movie in that
way were you playing with someone else
as well I was I was I was playing with
someone else in the same on the same
screen so a split screen and this is
where I actually one of the problems was
so the map i played on was this map in a
canyon it looked pretty good like it
looked like again it was out of a Star
Wars movie but the problem was because
my screen was so small because it was so
narrow the map was super vertical and so
I had a pretty hard time I split goes
down yeah I goes down horizontally in
middle and so I had to you know it was
hard as I sometimes keep track of the
storm troopers because you know I could
I was on the canyon floor a storm
trooper was you know way above the lack
of stability of it yeah yep and so
occasionally I would run into the
situation where there would be someone
shooting at me and I was looking all
around looking up and down and just
because my screen is so small right and
actually see there that sounds like me
every single game I play by doing
another excuse yeah i mean i don't know
like it could have been just that I'm
bad but I actually thought that it was
it just wasn't that visible okay kids
these days love to talk about frame rate
so let's talk about frame rate so the
this is another problem it felt a little
in precise because the game was running
at 30 frames a second and I'm used to
shooters running at 60 frames a second
right icon how important is that like a
shooter running at 60 frames a second
always that such a big deal so it's
really it's a big deal for precision
with timing like timing of shots like if
you you know if you're lining up a shot
you want to know that when you pull the
trigger there's very little difference
between when you pull the trigger when
the shotguns are your gun so the higher
the frame rate the more that is like
instantaneous gochu okay yeah and we
both saw the trailer yesterday we were
both super excited by I think there's a
ton of potential in this game than you
think yeah I do too and I think the
co-op mode that I saw was you know
pretty road as far as hormones go but
like again like I said that just the
style of it is amazing and I'm really
going to have to see you know the actual
multiplayer before I'm going to make any
judgment about the game what well the
multiplayer is absolutely fantastic but
how much you think this co-op mode will
add to display I really like my
knee-jerk reaction right now is that it
won't add too much it feels kind of just
like a co-op you know like a tack on
split screen co-op mode that they just
put in to have another option yeah but
we'll have to see what the full
experience is okay well
for more news features and analysis on
Star Wars Battlefront you stick around